everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk I'm
gonna take a bet
take a pound take advantage sorry heads
gone through the direction take
advantage of a greater opportunity where
I think I was kind of right a little bit
just the hair and one of my big talks
web 2.0 in 2008 monthly one of my most
famous talks changed a lot for me
everybody remembers to stop watching
methane lost you know thing that I said
but really one of the interesting things
I said in that was Smurf it up in
referencing if you have a passion built
your business around the thing you love
the most because then your work hardest
addict and then a lot of people out
there that you know talk about it do I
talk about things that are too small too
small of a niche but I think what's
really fascinating is what's happening
right now at this moment right now
Smurfs is going to be made into movies
the buzzes out the trailers out the
first trailers out
and so here's an interesting idea I just
wonder I can't help but wonder if
somebody was in the audience like mmm
I do love that Smurfette like that's my
passion and they built a community you
know here's my compromise if this is the
leading Smurf world right now with the
kind of budgets that Hollywood has heard
they're big they're private thing
they're kind of big you know I find it
very shocking if you didn't have the
dominant most vibrant most engaging
Smurf community that you couldn't pull
out a 25 you know K 10 K hundred K
depending on the size of the community
kind of advertising plan two years ago
you would say that's so stupid
we're gonna make money things work into
your passions
shifts happen on you all the time and
opportunities arise daily and this is an
absolutely perfect example here's the
cliff you need to care about everything
and it starts with yourself look
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
what do I want to do every day for the
rest of my life do that I promise you
can monetize that [ __ ] if you love Alf
do an Alf blog you collect Smurfs Smurfs
it up whatever you need to do do it